well I thought we'd give you a break but
they haven't let in haven't let up at
all thank you so very much
um
folks uh
I think this has been uh
we've been looking forward to this for a
long time
and it's uh wonderful to welcome you all
for the first time together leaders of
the Pacific Islands in Washington
you know the summit honors a deep
history that our Nations share
and a long-standing trade diplomatic
relationships and a and a shared fight
to defend freedom
and uh the sacrifices we made together
the Partnerships between our and among
our peoples
help bring an end to the bloody war in
the Pacific during World War II
and recently uh we honored the 80th
anniversary of the battle of guada canal
at a memorial in the Solomon Islands and
and today
Security in the Pacific and for the
Pacific Islanders remains as critical as
ever to us and I hope to you as well to
secure
the security of America quite frankly
and the world depends on your security
and the security of the Pacific Islands
and I really mean that
so this Summit is also about deepening
in our enduring commitment to each other
and our shared future
our commitment to tackling the climate
crisis which threatens all of us
we're seeing the consequences of climate
change around the world very vividly
including in the United States right now
and uh and I know your nation's feel it
acutely and for you all it's an
existential threat
it's an existential threat and we're
also committed to working together to
equitably uh rebuild the global economy
in the wake of covid-19 and Russia's War
you know to ensure an indo-pacific
region that's free and open
one that is stable and prosperous and
resilient and secure
a great deal of the history of our world
is going to be written in the inner
Pacific over the coming years and
decades
and the Pacific Islands are critical
voice in shaping that future
and that's why my Administration has
made it a priority to strengthen our
partnership with your countries and with
the Pacific Islands forum
I was honored to be the first U.S
president to uh to address the Forum
last year and vice president Harris
shared our vision for cooperation with
the Pacific Islands Forum at uh at your
leaders meeting this year we also
launched the partners in the Blue
Pacific initiative kind of poetic into
the partner in the Blue Pacific
but it's an initiative we we really care
about
um to more effectively coordinate with
our allies and partners around the world
to better meet the needs of the people
across the Pacific
that's why this historic Summit at this
historic Summit where we're making
additional and concrete commitments and
we're launching our Pacific partnership
strategy the first national U.S strategy
for Pacific Islands which is a key
component to our broader indo-pacific
strategy
we're also announcing more than 110
million dollars in expended U.S programs
uh to improve the lives of Pacific
Islanders
which includes more than 330 million in
new Investments to support climate
resilience and to build a sustainable
blue economies in the Pacific Islands
prepare for climate impacts on public
health and food security and to
strengthen sustainable development and
also to build a better early warning
capacity to predict prepare for and
respond to climate hazards that's going
to build on approximately 375 million in
climate programs we're currently have in
the region we're also taking several
important diplomatic steps and I'm proud
to announce that following appropriate
consultations we will recognize the Cook
Islands and and neoway uh as as
sovereign states
and we look forward to successfully
concluding negotiations for a compact
free association with three of our
closest Partners in the region
the Federated States of Micronesia the
Republic of the Marshall Islands and the
Republic of Palau
the United States is committed to
Consulting with all of you and engaging
collaboratively at every turn because
it's very much in our interest as well
as I hope yours
that's what this Summit is all about
and with your permission I'd also like
to briefly address the Shameless and
transparent effort by Russia to Annex
parts of the neighbor Ukraine the United
States I want to be very clear about
this the United States will never never
never recognize Russia's claims on
Ukraine Sovereign territory
this so-called referenda was a sham an
absolute sham the results were
manufactured in Moscow
and the true will of the Ukrainian
people is evident every day as they
sacrifice their lives to save their
people and maintain the independence of
their country and in defense of Freedom
as well Russia's assault on Ukraine
in pursuit of Putin's Imperial Ambitions
is a flagrant a flagrant violation of
the U.N Charter and the basic principles
of sovereignty and territorial integrity
I'm grateful to the Pacific island
leaders for standing up for these basic
principles and for your strong moral
leadership on global issues at the
United Nations I'm looking forward to
hearing from all of you and I'm even
looking forward to even more looking
forward to hosting you at my the white
house tonight for dinner I don't know
what's on the menu yet but I hope it's
good but all kidding aside I'm looking
forward to seeing you tonight and I'm
going to turn it over to secretary
Lincoln thank you very much Mr President